los vídeos que he hecho usando ejemplos
de payton los he hecho usando python 2
que es un tipo de versión estándar de
payton que tiene muchas implementaciones
a la fecha de la realización de este
vídeo pero también existe python 3
payton 3 que es una nueva versión de
payton pero no es compatible con python
2 y cuando digo que no es compatible eso
significa que si usan python 3 no
necesariamente podrá interpretar todo lo
que hayan escrito en python 2 pueden
tomar un programa que fue escrito en
python 2 este es un programa y digamos
que corre bien en python 2 y si lo
tratan de correr en python 3 no va a
funcionar eso es lo que significa que no
es compatible
no es compatible si no corre en python 3
es que no es compatible
esta es una buena manera de entender lo
que significa compatibilidad pero lo que
espera hacer en este vídeo es hacerles
ver que los programas que hice en los
últimos vídeos corren bien en python 2
pero no van a funcionar en python 3 y la
razón por la que no funcionan en python
3 es que payton 3 tiene una versión
diferente de la función input en esta
función input en python 2 si ustedes
usan la función input así como yo la use
puse un mensaje aquí para el usuario
para que supiera que teclear y cuando el
usuario teclea algo la función input
regresa o devuelve algo completamente
evaluado así que en este caso en el que
el usuario teclea un número obtenemos un
número como número una expresión
completamente evaluada obtenemos una
expresión
evaluada como lo vimos en los últimos
ejemplos si el usuario teclear a un 4
entonces el número 4 se asignaría a la
variable número si el usuario teclea da
literalmente 3 + 4
entonces se asignaría un 7 a la variable
número en python 3 la función input
funciona un poco diferente y si ustedes
tratan de correr este programa en python
3 será suficiente para que marque error
y deje de ejecutarse en python 3 la
función input no devuelve una expresión
evaluada devuelve un string y ya saben
string es una palabra que oirán mucho en
computación lo he explicado en varios
vídeos regresar a un string de lo que el
usuario teclea string
lo que el usuario
teclea
y que es un string es una cadena de
caracteres así que si el usuario teclea
aquí en python 22 por 6 entonces lo que
se va a almacenar en la variable número
es el resultado de 2 por 6 o sea 12 esta
expresión será evaluada en python 3 la
función no hará eso si tecleamos 2 por 6
lo que la función va a devolver no es la
expresión evaluada no es la expresión 2
por 6 evaluada sino que regresará una
cadena de caracteres un string que
contiene 2 por 6
esto lo podemos ver como un texto no
será interpretado y la variable número
tendrá ese string 2 x 6
y aquí la función range del número va a
marcar el error y el programa va a dejar
de correr porque trata la variable
número como una palabra y no como un
número si quieren que la función input
trabaje igual en python 3 entonces
tendrán que usar la función evans y
escribir la función input teclear el
mensaje entre comillas aquí dos puntos
comillas cerramos paréntesis y cerramos
paréntesis de la función e vale y lo que
ésta funcione vale hace es tomar este
string esta cadena de caracteres este
texto y lo evalúa entonces lo que pasa
en python 3 si se evalúa esto esto de
aquí en la función input esto va a
devolver 12 y en python 2 la función
imputa hace todo esto por nosotros en
python 3 la función input nos devuelven
string y es necesario usar la función
naval para poder obtener este 12 así que
sí corren
en python 3 y se interrumpe la ejecución
del programa es por esta razón y tendrán
que usar la función evans aquí